you
[Music]
I'm Austan wilt I lead product analytics
at SLAC this is a data product
management track and so I'm going to be
talking about the 18 months or so I
spent ending in January at slack as a
data product manager I have worked in
analytics more or less my entire career
I've always really loved the act of
trying to influence the business and the
product through the voice of data about
two years ago I was working at Pinterest
leasing leading monetization analytics
you may have seen them in the news today
it's a big day for Pinterest
and I was at one of those familiar times
in my career where I felt like I didn't
know where I was going I didn't know
what was next I felt a little bit stuck
I felt like I wanted to be able to move
into leading a broader data organization
but I had some pretty big gaps in my own
experience and skill set to get there
namely I had always been in analytics
and I didn't know much about data
engineering which felt like a big and
problematic blind spot also as a data
scientists and leading analytics teams
that's a support function I was very
familiar with having a very strong
opinion based in data but never
ultimately being the decision-maker and
that felt like a pretty big handicap
thinking about leading a bigger and
bigger team and I had a little person at
home and so work-life balance was really
on my mind and around then an
opportunity came my way to be a data
product manager at SLAC and it was a as
I'm sure you all know kind of a new role
you didn't know much about it the role
that was presented me to me at SLAC at
the time was pretty ill-defined it was
kind of like we want to invest more in
data we don't exactly know what that
looks like product managers at slack are
leaders and so we think we should hire a
product manager into the world of data
and that will help us figure out what to
do and how to really develop data it's
like and for me it checked all those
boxes I was getting it to work really
closely with data engineering I was
going to get to be a product manager and
a decision maker and get exposed to
product management at SLAC which was
really exciting and I'd be an Icee so a
little bit better work/life balance
potentially and so I jump at the
opportunity I moved over
to slack and when I got there you know I
did kind of the rounds talking to people
in the business and what I heard was the
very typical thing that you hear a lot
in analytics which is we don't have the
data that we need we don't really trust
the data that we have and when it comes
down to it data is just not making the
impact that we need it to make on the
business and on the way that we build
product so I said okay great that sounds
very familiar to me I'm working in
analytics a long time that I said okay
you know I'm a data product manager I
work with data engineering I'm kind of
in this back room back-end role and so I
kind of put my head down and went to
work was data engineering and it was it
checked all those boxes and all of those
things that I wanted it to be I learned
a ton about data engineering became a
lot more technical than I had in the
past I learned a lot about being a
product manager and a decision maker a
lot about engineering sprin said a lot
about process he is and we were making a
ton of progress we changed the way we
worked a ton we felt more productive we
were making better decisions building
better products getting better outcomes
but I picked my head up maybe six or
nine months later and kind of went back
into the business and I heard the same
things that I heard when I got there
which was we don't have enough data we
don't trust the data we have and it's
not having the impact that it's supposed
to have which was pretty disheartening
because it felt like we were making so
much progress how is it not having an
impact on the outcome and what I
realized was we had gotten caught up in
the false sense of local progress when
we weren't really focused on the outcome
we weren't solving the actual problem
that we needed to solve and so we really
changed the way that we were working and
the big theme was we have to focus on
that ultimate outcome just like things
had always been in analytics we have to
be focused on the value that data is
ultimately providing to the business we
can't get caught up in this false sense
of you know we're more efficient we have
a higher throughput in our engineering
teams and we think we're doing better
Road mapping process ease and all this
stuff we have to focus on that outcome
or we're not going to move the needle
and we're not
to make the impact that we need to make
so that's what I'm going to talk about
today is kind of how we solved those
problems and some of the key principles
that we use to really change from you
know that false feeling of progress to
actual progress in the business and so
the three biggest things that we did the
first one was in increasing curation as
we brought in the audience we had really
been solving for really advanced
technical folks giving them great access
to our data warehouse and to data tools
but we were ignoring this broader
audience at the company and so we spent
a lot of time thinking about how do we
curate data for a broader audience at
SLAC the second was balancing
foundational investments with immediate
value to the business and this is the
age-old tension between engineering
teams that really want to build exciting
interesting technically foundational
things from the ground up and the
distraction that can some kind sometimes
come from a stakeholder requests and
stakeholder needs and we really spent
some thoughtful time on how to balance
that foundational work with that kind of
more immediate and urgent stakeholder
requests and then the third thing
connecting engineers with the end users
maybe the most obvious but also
definitely the most important and
something that we had sort of totally
mists where if we want to impact that
ultimate outcome maybe the best way we
can do it is just to get the engineers
in front of those stakeholders so that
they can really internalize that outcome
that they're trying to drive firsthand
all right so the first one increasing
curation as you brought in the audience
and originally at SLAC we had lived
entirely in this bottom of the period
pyramid era where we had this great data
warehouse we were focused on building
super powerful data tools there was no
access controls no real curation it was
really aimed at these advanced day
teasers and that's really data
scientists they had access to all data
anything that you want
they could do anything with it and they
had really advanced really powerful
tools they were really happy the data
scientists at slack felt like our data
warehouse is great our data tools are
great everything's great
the problem was that if you stepped
outside of that audience nobody had the
skill set and nobody had the tools that
they needed to get at any of the data so
those data scientists were a huge
blocking point they had to do every
curation every time anyone needed
anything it had to go through one of
those humans which was a big problem and
a huge thing that was leading to that
message of we don't have data in the
business we just don't have data and so
what we did was we said we need to
devour start by defining categories of
audiences beyond just those data
scientists and acknowledged that we need
to solve for them and so we chose two
additional audiences the next level
above data scientists we call business
analysts or subject matter experts and
that's people who data isn't their
full-time job but data is a part of
their job and they're going to want to
get hands-on they're gonna want to
really understand data they're gonna
want to get into the nitty gritty and
into the details but in more of a
part-time way where they need to be
informed they need to understand they
have deep knowledge in an area but they
may or might may or may not even know
sequel and so they need a little bit
more hand-holding in order to get there
and they don't need access to all of the
data slack they in fact need a slightly
more curated experience because they're
not going to be spending the time and
energy to really understand how to
navigate you know whether they should be
using demo user's v3 or dim all users of
e3 latest they're not going to keep up
and so what we defined that we wanted to
do for them was say they're going to get
access to curated data sandbox is not
the whole data warehouse but we're going
to curate for them sand boxes of data
that are relevant to their business area
instead of having access to all
functionality we're going to give them
reporting and exploration functionality
which means they don't just get a report
of metrics but they get some kind of
area where they can play with the data
do some deep exploration on their own
but with some good guardrails in place
and then we're going to make sure that
they get a user-friendly tool set with
some education and so it doesn't need to
be you know a foolproof tool where they
can just on the first day come in and
use it but we're going to provide them a
tool that's a little bit more advanced
than that or with some education they
can learn how to use it but not nearly
the level that those advanced data users
are getting and then we do find a third
audience which is everybody everybody at
the company all employees and leadership
and we said okay for that audience they
want access to the narrowest set of data
the most limited set it needs to be the
most highly curated the most
self-explanatory the easiest to use
primarily what they're going to get is
just reports and maybe they can adjust
time windows and things like that but
primarily the functionality that they're
going to get is just reporting and their
tool set needs to be super user-friendly
no education really necessary just a
pretty dashboard sort of thing so now
we've got these three audiences and
we've said okay we've only really solved
for one we need to solve for these
additional - how are we going to do it
the biggest gap here was we had no plan
to do any curation because at the bottom
of the pyramid you don't and so how are
we going to get there how are we going
to curate our data and so we kind of
defined three very high-level very very
very simple steps we need to have
somebody whose job it is to define what
data people are going to need to use
somebody whose job it is to curate that
data and then somebody whose job is to
create that kind of visualization and
accessible area define is about working
with the business to say exactly what's
in this data set exactly what does it
mean detailed definitions things that
can be translated to the person who's
going to curate it and then when this
whole thing circles back that's also
going to work on education and adoption
to help people understand what's in
their data the curation step is about
operationalizing and that's where we say
okay who's going to build a scalable
data pipeline that's got alerting and
monitoring and as sl8 and is going to
arrive at 8 or 9 a.m. every day reliably
and doesn't break that's also the place
where we say instead of building one-off
data sets every time that we're doing
some kind of standard data modeling and
developing some practices best practices
on the back end and then the
visualization step and that could be as
simple as just loading something into a
dashboard or it could be more complex if
you want to create a sandbox where you
need to do some data modeling specific
to your visualization tool you're going
to build that reporting and exploration
functionality and then you're going to
bring that to people you're going to
educate them how to use it and you're
going to get it in front of them so that
they adopt it so then now that we've
defined those audiences and these steps
the last remaining pieces okay who is
going to do each of these things and
this was really important for us because
previously we had a data science team
who was doing everything who was
responsible for end to end all data
things in the business and it was really
a problem because it meant that they
weren't spending much time on
interpretation and analysis because they
were also responsible for data pipelines
and data visualizations and all of these
things that they were both not great at
didn't love and was taking up a lot of
their time and energy and so we added
data engineering to the mix and we'll
talk about that later that we actually
started throwing them into the business
and embedding them as kind of the
curators of these data sets
turns out engineers are much better no
surprise at building sustainable
repeatable data pipelines than analysts
are and we also built on an IT business
intelligence team and we said that
they're responsible at those top two
levels of the pyramid for beautiful data
visualizations that people in the
business can adopt and use turns out our
data scientists weren't super enthused
about spending a bunch of time on making
things pretty pretty and accessible to
execs no surprise there again and so
they weren't doing a great job of it
anyway there's an entire function called
business intelligence where people are
really good at that and so we created
that team and made it happen
we also separated out between product
and business product data is a very
different ballgame than kind of
corporate business data so we separated
the world and said on the product side
we're going to use our data engineering
and on the business side we're going to
also utilize an IT data engineering team
that's thinking more about data
integrations then about logging and
product and behavioral data and so now
we've got kind of this audiences that
we've defined we defined the steps that
need to happen to bring the data to them
and we have set up this new
structure and these new people and
figured out who's gonna do what job to
make this all happen and so where is it
gotten us first of all it took us a
while to set this all up because we
literally created entire new teams based
on this new plan which was a non-trivial
exercise we were also starting from a
world of like muddy chaos in terms of
data you could find the same data in
four places and it would mean different
things and so it's taken us it took
probably a year to get from this is the
previous three slides this is our plan -
we actually have these people in place
in the business doing this work but the
results have been great they've been
really really good a few kind of key
themes of things that we've seen one is
we have trustworthy and consistent data
that comes from high-quality data
pipelines so that message if we don't
trust the data when it comes to this
data we're curating has gone away the
data is trustworthy it's really
high-quality which is fantastic
self-serve data access that message that
we're hearing of people don't have
access to the data that they need in the
cases where we've done the curation and
done the work that message has also gone
away because people have this self-serve
data access now in the places that we've
put in the work to do it and more time
for data scientists to do actual
analysis which is making them happier
because they have more time to do what
really provides value to the business
and is making our stakeholders much
happier all right so that's one piece of
the puzzle next piece balancing
foundational investments with immediate
value to the business this is again that
kind of age-old struggle of do I do the
strategic stuff that's going to make a
big impact later down the road or do I
do the urgent stuff that someone's
banging on my door for today and so on
the left when it's where it says
previous focus that's the way that we
used to do planning and data engineering
we used to all say in a room at the
beginning of a quarter and we'd say what
is great look like a year or two years
three years from now and we would kind
of paint a picture of what our data
warehouse need to look like and what
data it's like should be and then we'd
say what's the next quarter of work that
we need to do to get us a step closer to
that and we build a beautiful roadmap
and a beautiful quarterly plan
and then of course lo and behold the
quarter would start and the stakeholders
would start banging down our door and
saying I need this now I need this now I
need this now and we'd do all that stuff
and then we get to the end of the
quarter and we would do barely any of
the stuff we planned for and a whole lot
of randomizing or things falling down or
immediate stakeholder requests which was
really frustrating and we'd have these
talks every quarter about how we're
gonna do better of doing the stuff that
we planned for and less of the
stakeholder requests we through all of
that out and said okay we're clearly
just doing it wrong and we said what we
need to do is take a much more balanced
approach out of the gate in terms of how
we're doing planning we said okay we're
gonna upfront allocate time to both of
these things both the immediate
stakeholder needs and that long-term
strategic investment stuff and then
we're gonna make a plan to kind of wall
off our resources in order to actually
make that happen in both directions the
way that we approach in the planning
process is first of all we actually
define three buckets because what we
figured out was that there's a bucket
called business critical initiatives
that is the stuff that you have no
choice so before you even sit down just
talk about strategic work versus
immediate stakeholder work you have to
cover your business critical initiatives
and what that means for us at slack we
do okay are so any high level company o
carriers that have a data engineering
component we have to support them we
have no choice and then there's always
like this public commitment stuff so for
example if we at our annual conference
announced that we're going to be HIPAA
compliant seven months from now any data
engineering work that has to happen for
us to get there we have to do it we have
no choice and so step one in the
planning process became business
critical initiatives make sure we find
them and identify them and plan for them
and just kind of say that time is carved
out and it has to happen we usually go
through a process of what's the minimum
viable amount of work can we do in order
to satisfy those things because they're
not strategic we just have to make them
happen and let's set aside that time and
then once we're done with that we look
at strategic projects and immediate
stakeholder value projects in the
strategic bucket we've really scoped
down the projects that we're going to do
in that bucket and so it has to be only
the few most high priority
things because we really want to solve
for actually making progress and
achieving things and that's all of the
foundational stuff that's all of the
infrastructure overhauls that's tech
debt that's new explorations all of
those things that's always the most fun
great brainstorming session with the
engineers and then in the immediate
stakeholder value section what we've
really found there is that if we plan
for it upfront we do a much better job
of it because instead of it feeling
really really reactive and like we're
just doing things that people shout at
us all throughout the quarter if we take
the time and energy to go into the
business figure out what those asks are
and plan for them first of all we can
say a lot more no because we have our
act together upfront we're saying here's
all your requests here's the ones that
are above the fold and here's the ones
we're saying no to which people are a
lot more receptive to in a more planned
way and we can approach them in a much
more strategic manner so we can look
across the business and think about all
the stakeholder requests that are
happening and how are we going to
achieve them in a way that feels more
thoughtful and maybe also sneaks us into
this green bucket of strategic projects
because now that we're planning for them
we can add 10 or 20% of time and scope
and do them in a more thoughtful more
strategic more repeatable way this also
allows us to plan our resources better
most people are going to do projects
across all of those things projects
across all of that space all of those
buckets but we started saying also we
should take our top couple strategic
projects the things that we said were
the most important to us we should map
people to them and we should hide them
and we shouldn't let them work on
anything else so that if a business
critical project ends up bigger than we
thought it was or a stakeholder comes
banging down the door with something
really important that these people are
not up for grabs because they're hiding
somewhere and no one's ever talking to
them and so they're really going to make
progress on those strategic projects and
then we did the same thing for people
who are responsible the stakeholders and
that has been a really interesting
experience because it's taken the
message from this stakeholder work is
distracting and we want to minimize it
to your
does that stakeholder work it's really
really valuable to the business and
you're responsible to do it in the most
thoughtful way possible you're
responsible to those stakeholders and
we're going to reinforce how important
that work is and that is entirely your
job and so it's really shifted the
mentality for the people in that bucket
from this is the distracting crappy work
that I'm just trying to get through to
this is a really interesting and
valuable part of my job that I'm gonna
focus on and try to win okay so where
has this landed us first of all we're
much better reliably delivering on those
critical business initiatives because
we're we're mapping out time for them
which is great it has helped a lot in
terms of data engineering reputation at
SLAC we are a much more reliable team
making meaningful progress against
select strategic work we've really
focused our efforts on what are the top
few things every quarter and making sure
that we're making meaningful progress
against them which has been happening
and then the last one is that better
prioritize stakeholder projects with
more thoughtful engineering solutions
which has also just totally changed the
dynamic in the game in terms of how data
engineering is viewed and how we're
operating in terms of our relationship
with those stakeholders and what we're
able to achieve for them over time and I
will say lastly like we used to feel a
lot on a hamster wheel like we weren't
really getting anywhere
quarter-to-quarter things weren't
getting better over time and taking this
more kind of intentional thoughtful
approach has created a world where you
can really feel the progress every
quarter and things are better they're
more efficient they're more effective or
set up better as we move forward which
feels really good two people on the team
okay the last one which is maybe the
simplest and maybe the most obvious but
we completely missed it in the beginning
was connect engineers with their end
users we've really seen that more
contact more context and more connection
with those end users has by far yielded
a better result we have four sub teams
in our data engineering org we have a
data model an architecture team which is
basically like our data pipelines
traditional data engineering team we
have a data tools team that builds and
user tools we have a data platform team
which is responsible for
to access the data warehouse and we have
a data infrastructure team and we used
to just think of them as four teams and
we've remapped the world kind of like
this which really shows you who's
responsible - who who should be close to
stakeholders in who shouldn't and so we
identified that this data model and
architecture team and the data tools
team they need a lot of contact with
stakeholders they are directly
responsible to people in the business
because they're either building tools
that people in the business use or
they're building data sets that people
in the business use so we need to make
sure that they're close to the
stakeholders this data platform team
kind of answers to those two teams and
they should be pulling a lot of road map
items from what those two teams need and
then data infrastructure is very
naturally or much more back-end team and
just drawing the world like this has
allowed us to identify that hey
yes data infrastructure engineers you
can tell stakeholders to go away they
should not be bothering you but data
tools team we need to find tons of
opportunities for you to interact with
stakeholders and spend time in the
business and we've really focused on
that on the data tools side is tons of
interaction with stakeholders and in the
business and on the data modeling and
architecture side what we've done is
we've split the team into kind of two
sub groups we've said we're gonna have a
centralized foundational team whose job
it is to build horizontal data sets
across the business do foundations tools
best practices and then we're going to
take half that team and we're gonna
actually embed them directly in the
business to get them really really close
to their stakeholders and what that
looks like for us we've actually done
the same team thing with business
intelligence which if you remember is
that visualization function is we've
created these data pods in the business
we used to just have data scientists
from the product analytics team in the
business but we've thrown data engineers
in there alongside them and we've said
you're not supporting the analytics team
you're embedded you're partnering with
them and you're embedded alongside them
same thing for IT business intelligence
so now in our product teams we have all
of these three functions working
together so now that data engineer isn't
sitting somewhere in a different floor
just taking requirements and directions
from an analyst they're in the business
they're building their own roadmap and
they're really able to assess into
what are the most important things to do
and really maintain that connection with
value they know what the business needs
are they know ultimately what the
stakeholder is trying to do and so
instead of taking filtered requirements
they're best able to say this is the
data that we need to curate this is what
we need to build in order to have the
biggest impact on the business and again
what we've seen has been really positive
I will say that you know the old like
should I be embedded should I be
centralized doesn't come without cost
there's been some bumps along the roads
in the data engineering world embedding
data engineers into product teams has
not been a totally seamless thing and we
continue to iterate on how that goes to
make them feel excited about it get them
to have as much impact as possible but
overall it's been really really positive
in the data tools world that data tools
team and data engineering they're
increased exposure to the stakeholders
has resulted in just a lot more high
value work being done on their side both
in the tools that they're building and
in our experiments framework which
they're responsible for on the data
engineering embedded in the pillars side
we've made some really really measurable
progress for example we now have metrics
in every product area with interactive
data visualizations that people can use
which is huge there's data sets in every
product product area that people can
really trust can really rely on have
been curated by those data engineers and
visualized by our IT team and we've
ended up with a really nice set of
repeatable and scalable data pipelines
that we didn't have before it slack some
of it exists in a foundational
centralized way and some of them exist
in individual product areas and again I
feel like this you know connect
engineers with stakeholders is the most
kind of trivial and obvious thing but it
feels like actually the biggest missing
piece in that world of you know we're
trying to ultimately drive an outcome
for our stakeholders and yet we weren't
at all connected to them and this is of
all three things definitely the one that
has just made the the easiest and
biggest impact on our ability to go from
that false sense of progress that we had
before that wasn't having the impact
that we wanted to really really making
an impact on
that's it thanks
just pretty quick one when you wall off
people is that do those teams rotate do
like I'm walled off for this week or
this quarter or do you just they're
always walled off like do you rotate the
people for their jobs and a little bit
so on the embedded side those people
really are embedded permanent is a
strong word but they have like moved
their chair to sit with a product team
just like the data scientists do and so
they really are dedicated to that work
we have debates all the time about how
long they're dedicated for the current
agreement is at least a quarter at a
time so that's a pretty significant
period of time that they're walled off
because there's so much business context
for them to get it and so I think
actually the longer that they're
embedded as long as they're happy with
it the better that that goes on the
backend side in those strategic projects
that's much more rotating a month at a
time maximum a quarter at a time if it's
a huge project where we just say like
you know instead of splitting your time
between different things for this entire
month or this entire quarter you're
going to focus on this and so it's much
more of a rotating thing which also from
an engineering perspective that's like
kind of one of the most coveted things
to get to do is just kind of put your
head down and build something really
cool and so I think the rotation there
is a lot more helpful hi I had a
question about the this slide you had
about that data pods embedded in the
product teams I'm guessing that
different engineers and different pods
share the same infrastructure but how do
you prevent like knowledge silos and
things like that like if one data
engineer is working on this product and
other danger is working on this product
but they share kind of the same
underlying data like how do you prevent
knowledge silos between those yeah
that's a good question and that's the
age-old problem right of either you're
gonna embed and so you're gonna get the
business value or you're gonna
centralized and you're gonna get you
know really good standardized things I
think having that centralized data
engineering team that they're a part of
and then they're embedded resource in a
pillar helps because there's still one
team they still belong to the data
engineering team they both they report
to the head of day
in architecture so they still spend a
lot of time together and that team is so
early-stage I think it now has nine
people on it and I think it had one
person on it last summer so it's still
pretty new and so they spend a lot of
time together embedded for them right
now means 70 or 80 percent embedded and
20 or 30 percent spending time with
their team on their processes and
building things on their side and so
they're putting I think even an
inordinate amount of time and energy
into that how do we do things in a
standard way who knows how that evolves
over time but for now they're really
focused on that how do we build things
in a standardized manner hi I'm just
wondering how big is the data
engineering team kind of at SLAC where
were you when this all started and like
how did you grow and for a team that's
really small say like two engineers yeah
how would we go about kind of taking
this kind of talk and trying to
implement it with something so small
yeah that's a good question so when I
got to slack I think two years ago data
engineering was maybe six or seven
people and the first my first day they
were doing quarterly planning actually
and it was happening on a post-it note
on someone's computer and I think now
they're around 30 in total I want to say
data engineers so it's grown really
substantially and it's gone from just
kind of one full of people into these
much more differentiated functions
obviously you don't get to do that if
you have two people and you have to be a
lot more you know kind of selective and
a lot more kind of all-around players
and so obviously you know you can't
probably afford to fully embed people in
the business and some of these concepts
you can't hide somebody in a back room
someone will find them right these are
luxuries of scale that you don't have
with two people but I think some of the
concepts still apply I would argue that
the first two pieces about curating data
for audiences and figuring out how to
find a balance are still really really
important and that the sort of you know
getting to embedded and that kind of
stuff is stuff that you have to get to
later when you have more scale
hi I'm very curious about the IT
business intelligence job title I used
to hire into analyst roles and I could
never tell what business intelligence
was and so I'm interested to see the
house that redeveloping there and what
what tasks are associated with that how
do you split that up between the data
scientist data engineer and yeah TV
person yeah good question that's been
really interesting at SLAC so one of the
interesting things about slack is that
it started as a very b2c consumer
company and then it's kind of developed
into also an enterprise sales company
and so we have this really interesting
mix of people who work at slack a lot of
which come from like b2c tech and then
we have a lot of people that come from
the enterprise world and in the b2c tech
world you end up with data science and
product analytics teams and data
engineering teams and in the b2b world
and enterprise a lot of times you don't
have those teams you just have an RIT
team doing all of your data stuff that's
like we have both which is really really
interesting and has really been valuable
to me to see kind of the value and the
skill set on the other side concretely
what it's meant for us is we bought
liquor we didn't have a data
visualization tool that anyone without a
great skillset couldn't utilize we had a
our data tools team has built a great
homegrown tool but it's incredibly
powerful and incredibly accessible and
so we bought liquor RIT VI team did that
they were just formed about nine months
ago that I TDI team and right now we
have two folks who are fully embedded
and product that will continue to grow
this year because it's a fairly new
thing and literally what they do is they
work with the business they take the
data that gets curated by the data
product data engineering team and then
they build a data model and look or
through look ml so that it can get
visualized and explored in liquor and
then they work with people in the
business ok what data do you need ok I'm
gonna work the data engineering team to
make sure I have it it's in my data
model in explorable way they build
dashboards and then they build those
hand boxes where people can kind of
drag-and-drop dimensions build their own
tables do their own exploration and then
they work on that education and adoption
so those top couple layers of the
pyramid where people need that curation
even though data engineering is curating
that I TV i person is really
in the business helping with the
requirements building their own look FML
data model which is very different from
the data model that we have in the data
warehouse and then working with people
in the business on kind of how to use it
how to answer their questions using it
and that sort of thing and honestly it
was something that we were doing such a
bad job of that with our data scientists
and data engineers and the ITB I people
are just such pros at it they're
fantastic at it so having them come in
and just entirely focus on that has
really up leveled our ability to get
data to people in the business second
they're building on one of the previous
questions and also you mentioned that it
took about like 12 months to actually
implement this within the organization
I'm sure there were a bunch of
challenges not just on the technical
side but also like building creating
this new function and defining this like
we're what do you think were some of the
key like inflection points in progress
over those 12 months and particularly
interested in whether those inflection
points were kind of coming from like
Bottoms Up support or whether there was
some kind of like key top down you know
executive support that came along the
way yeah I think it's been a healthy
combination of both in the sense that a
lot of what we needed was an org design
that we could hire out into that makes
sense so that first section about you
know we're going to define these
different stages and these new audiences
we're going to build out the data
engineering team from six or seven to
thirty we're gonna hire this IT bi team
that's all top-down stuff right
presenting them an org structure and
this audience stuff that they can get
behind that they can be willing to
invest in and they wanted to but part of
what they were looking to us for was how
do we make this additional investment in
the data world and so there was a lot of
top-down work in terms of drawing out
what this meant and then getting
headcount and hiring out teams that was
a huge part of I think why this took so
long but also the bottoms-up part was
really important in the way that we've
really tackled that was we had seven
product pillars at slack and
implementing this stuff across seven
different places was just going to be
too cumbersome and ever going to happen
on day one and so we would kind of pick
one place and we would say
okay in a bottoms-up way this pillar is
product areas super excited about data
and they need this specific thing so
let's throw at them like two data
scientists a data engineer and an IT BI
person all at once in a world where all
the other pillars maybe have like 10% of
that support let's just concentrate it
all in one place and let's kind of get a
chance to from the bottom up figure out
what this model actually looks like in
practice and iterate on it before we
start to spread it and we're still in
those seven product pillars were like
three and a half so we're about halfway
through in terms of fully building out
this model because we kind of started
from one and then we say okay this is
working and this is how we want to
iterate copy it to somewhere else and
kind of edit it for that area of the
business and so I think that like
resourcing came and that buy-in top down
and then the bottoms up is where you
really start to see it in action and
iterate on it
[Music]